tell me you've you've done some accent  work I'm Jews oh yes you did I did yeah  yeah William conquer our dialect coach  kept saying no that's not it I was  trying to play somebody cocky and it  seemed like every one of our sessions  would go like this at all right start  with the dice oh oh it's a it's a bloody  why Sir Thomas you know I don't want a  smashing right in the face and all I  want is our rooms handling Audrey happy  but you also you didn't you teach mr.  Hanks cows well he eats rides alone of  course when I'm on the phone - I know in  makeup  [Music]  his father had a long-standing holiday  that he wanted to be released from work  with and his kids sit the most adorable  video to our director yeah well we hope  that you will release our dad we know  that you haven't for possible rain cover  shots but there's any way you can come  so we could have a traditional holiday  yeah that came through and your daughter  said oops I just tread on the cat  [Applause]  you